hi in this video I will talk about how
to crack the entrance examination of JNU
and it is for come it's a common
entrance exam for Biotechnology is known
as CEEB that means common entrance
examination for Biotechnology in this
video I will one-by-one analyze the exam
pattern the subject weight age and also
give you some tips and tricks to qualify
this exam now once upon a time I also
gave this exam and got a rank of two so
it's not a hard exam and believe me this
exam is very easy if you study
methodologically and study a little bit
every day you have to study less but
study smart so here are some quick trips
quick tips and tricks that you can use
to study for this exam for example first
and foremost you need to have your
basics cleared second thing a daily
practice of mcq would help you to save
your time and decide better and also you
have to choose wisely in the day of
answering the exam so in the exam hall
you have to decide whether to answer
this question or not because example is
the most important time which decides
your rank okay now coming to the exam
pattern the exam paper has two parts
Part A and Part B Part A you have to
answer 60 questions but there are more
than 60 questions all these questions
are majorly from biology but there are
also physics chemistry and mathematics
based questions and mostly these
questions are ten plus two level so
there are total 60 questions that you
have to answer and here you can choose
wisely to answer but there is a big
conduit because in the part a the
negative marking is pretty huge
because it is half a marks negative
marking so if you correctly answer it
you get a plus one if you mistake you do
a mistake then you get minus half so
that's why playing part a
pretty difficult so you have to
carefully analyze the questions in part
a and answer and decide how many to
answer in Part A Part B is relatively
easy because the negative marking is
less in Part B you also have 60
questions but you have more than 60
questions and you have options more than
60 questions so you among that you have
to choose 60 questions and definitely if
you cancer it correctly you win three
marks if you don't answer it correctly
one marks is deducted so you have to be
again careful about the negative marking
and it's not that hard but you have to
decide if you are not sure about it
don't take the risk of doing a negative
mark because negative one is really
lower down your ranks and here is the
vintage analysis so among biology mostly
and frequently asked portions are
molecular biology cell biology and
biochemistry apart from that there are
some amount of microbiology immunology
questions another important aspect is
ecology and evolution quite a lot of
questions every year was asked from
ecology and evolution so this part is
pretty important now in case of physics
most important part is mechanics current
electricity and waves and oscillations
now there are other categories as well
but what my strategy was I didn't look
at other categories I clearly targeted
mechanics a little bit of wave of waves
and oscillations and very little of
current electricity so let's say there
are a lot of questions from mechanics
and if I can get all of the questions
from mechanics correct then I get a plus
point instead of studying quite a lot of
topics but not in depth won't help
instead you can take the risk of
studying less topics in depth such that
you can answer all of these questions so
this was my strategy after that
chemistry voyage a vast amount of
question is asked from organic chemistry
mainly the name reactions
almost all the chapters of organic
chemistry important apart from that they
asked quite a lot of physical chemistry
questions which are mainly analytical
and numerical type questions whereas I
completely ignored inorganic chemistry
for this exam because in Europe any
chemistry is pretty huge and hard to
remember all those informations I
decided not to attempt from any of the
inorganic chemistry questions now in
case of maths again a lot of question is
asked from calculus for my time I only
prepared for calculus and coordinate
geometry because I was cool at these two
topics in class tools so I studied more
mostly calculus and coordinate geometry
and did you didn't let go one of the
questions in the exam so I answered all
of the questions regarding calculus and
coordinate geometry in the exam that
gave me quite a lot of positive marks so
that means so one of the possible
possible thing that you can do is not to
study a lot of the topics but read up
reduce the amount of topic that you
learn but learn in depth of some of
those topics which would help mainly
calculus is one of the important focus
and also coordinate geometry or algebra
so that would help you to answer the
Part B questions so this is the weight
edge analysis of all and as for
resources I used a question Explorer for
last spin years and this is quite a
quite a nice one
I give the link in the description and
also pathfinder academies mcq questions
which are important for i PJM gnu etc
etc this is quite useful I also used it
apart from that for physics chemistry
and mathematics I used a 40-day to
breathe poop for preparation which I get
from Hamazon and this book is pretty
important and pretty good because it
gives you only the concepts not much
it's pretty good and it comes with a lot
of tests and a lot of exercises so I
used this resources if you like my video
comes up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you